(APPLAUSE)
IF YOU'RE TRAVELING AND DON'T
WANT TO STAY IN A HOTEL,
I RECOMMEND AIRBNB.
YOU CAN ACTUALLY RENT OUT
A ROOM AT SOMEONE'S PLACE
OR RENT OUT...
THIS ISN'T A COMMERCIAL FOR
AIRBNB, BY THE WAY, BECAUSE A
LOT OF TIMES WHAT HAPPENS IS YOU
GO TO RENT OUT A ROOM AND YOU
FIND OUT, "OH, THIS IS NORMALLY
THE DOG'S BATHROOM AND I'M
PAYING HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS FOR
IT."
BUT THEY HAVE VERY SPECIFIC
TITLES OF THE TYPE OF PLACE
YOU'RE RENTING, LIKE THIS ONE:
"HEATED GYPSY WAGON WITH HEART."
I THINK THEY MEAN AN ACTUAL
HEART IN THAT INSTANCE.
COMEDIANS, I WANT YOU TO COME UP
WITH LISTINGS FOR AIRBNB RENTALS
THAT YOU WOULD NEVER WANT TO
STAY AT.
FOR EACH FUNNY LISTING, YOU GET
250 POINTS.
60 SECONDS ON THE CLOCK, AND GO!
BETH STELLING?
>> NUDIST COLONY, B-Y-O-BACON.
(LAUGHING)
>> Chris: WHY WOULD THEY NOT
HAVE BACON?
POINTS!
YES, RORY SCOVEL?
>> "MEGA-RELIGIOUS FAMILY
UPSTAIRS."
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS!
BETH STELLING?
>> CABBAGE PATCH-- MUST HAVE
BIRTH CERTIFICATE.
>> Chris: YES, THAT'S HOW YOU
KNOW IT'S A REAL CABBAGE PATCH.
SIGNED BY XAVIER ROBERTS, IT'S
RIGHT ON THE BUTT.
WHY WOULD I KNOW THAT?
POINTS.
RORY SCOVEL?
>> RECENTLY FEATURED ON
"GHOST HUNTERS".
(LAUGHING)
>> Chris: POINTS.
JON DORE?
>> "CEILING-SCHMEILING,
$800 A MONTH."
>> Chris: SO YOU'RE GOING TO BE
THERE FOR THE WHOLE MONTH.
POINTS, WELL DONE.
RORY?
>> "SURROUND YOURSELF IN THE
ESSENCE OF MY FATHER'S LAST
BREATH."
(LAUGHTER)
>> THEY GET SAD.
>> Chris: I WOULD STAY THERE.
THAT SOUNDS NICE.
POINTS.
BETH STELLING?
>> MY UTERUS, FULLY FURNISHED,
NO CATS!
(APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: I'LL GIVE YOU POINTS
FOR YOUR UTERUS.
THAT'S THE STRANGEST THING
I'VE EVER SAID TO A WOMAN.
THAT IS THE END OF THAT ROUND.